alors est-ce que tu veux jouer ou non
non je veux bien jouer non mais
excuse-moi j'étais un mauvais client
j'étais pas du tout
c'est pareil
alors est-ce que Jean-Louis Murat vous
êtes prêt pour une interview jugement
dernier
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Louis
vous pensez à la mort une demi-heure par
jour
ah bon
donc vous êtes prêt pour l'interview
jugement dernier
Jean-Louis Murat quand tu étais petit
as-tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau
de ta maîtresse
jamais
il était plein
ah tu enfermé des élèves de sexe féminin
dans les cabinets
ils étaient en plein air
as-tu joué au docteur avec tes copains
jamais
malade c'est bien merci
Jean-Louis Murat avec ce professeur
d'anglais qui t'a fait lire corridon
es-tu sûr qu'il ne sait vraiment rien
passé
sexuellement tu veux dire bien sûr que
non
Jean-Louis Murat
as-tu utilisé ta notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
des fois les bonnes places au resto tout
ça absorbe tu encore des substances
illicites jamais
jamais
pour ça que ton purgatoire éventuel mais
étranger
t'est-il arrivé d'avoir envie de la
femme d'un autre
j'aime et le principe
est-il arrivé de tromper ta femme jamais
de tromper ta maîtresse
j'ai jamais une maîtresse
ne serait-ce qu'une fois
emmerder le monde par plaisir
jamais et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu